Arrivé trop tôt ou trop tard sur les lieux,
les bombardements aériens
ont manqué leur cible.
L'artillerie navale n'a pas fait mieux.
L'heure précoce du débarquement
déterminée par la marée,
ne lui a pas laissé le temps
de mener à bien le pilonnage prévu.
Le gros de l'attaque échoit aux GI de la
célèbre "Big Red One", unité expérimentée.
On leur a adjoint le 116ᵉ bataillon,
composé de jeunes boys qui n'ont
encore jamais connu l'épreuve du feu.
Pour éviter les tirs ennemis,
les barges ont été mises
à l'eau trop loin des côtes,
au milieu d'une mer agitée.
Les hommes s'y entassent,
chargés comme des mules.
Quand le bruit du premier éclat
percute nos oreilles,
on se jette à plat ventre dans les vomissures
sans plus surveiller la côte qui s'approche,
raconte Robert Capa.
Seul photographe présent ce jour-là.
À peine sur la plage,
les hommes sont cueillis par une défense
allemande quasi intacte,
qui les tire comme des lapins.
Le vent a fait monter la mer
plus vite que prévu.
Les vagues d'assaut suivantes
s'empalent sur les obstacles de Rommel,
obligeant les hommes
à débarquer dans une eau profonde.
Incapable d'avancer, tous se regroupent
au centre de la plage,
réduit à envoyer le même message
d'une effroyable concision :
" Sommes cloués sur place
par artillerie ennemie.
Crucifiés plutôt."
Comme le montrent les rares
clichés restants de Capa.
Tous les autres ayant été
accidentellement détruits.
Un courant violent déporte les embarcations.
Les hommes se noient, entraînés
par la charge de leur matériel.
La mer est rouge.
Rouge comme Omaha la sanglante,
où les hommes sont en perdition.
Le commandement américain
envisage de stopper l'offensive.
Ce choix désespéré signifierait
l'abandon des troupes déjà débarquées.
Les morts et les blessés
se comptent déjà par centaines.
Leur sacrifice aurait été vain.
L'arrêt des opérations laisserait
aussi ouverte une énorme brèche,
sur la continuité du front Allié.
Alors même que la gigantesque machine
de guerre est lancée à plein régime.
En effet, ce 6 juin,
le jour maintenant levé,
dévoile l'armada de 7000 navires,
qui s'approchent des côtes normandes.
Comme toujours, Ike n'est pas loin.
Et à 9 h 45, il s'adresse au monde
et aux siens par la voix de la BBC.
Que tous les hommes qui aiment
la liberté soient des nôtres.
Que rien n'ébranle votre foi.
Rien n'arrêtera nos coups.
Ensemble, nous vaincrons.
Sur un front de 70 km,
il y a pratiquement un bateau tous les 250 m,
couvert par 11 000 avions.
6 h après avoir débarqué à Omaha,
les boys sont toujours bloqués
au pied de la falaise.
Les Américains privilégient
toujours les hommes,
quel que soit le surcroît
d'intendance nécessaire.
Même les premières vagues d'assaut sont
pourvues d'une structure médicale bien rodée,
avec médecins et infirmiers,
pour prendre en charge
au plus vite les blessés.
Fussent-ils des ennemis.
Jamais les secours n'auront été plus utiles
que sur Omaha la Sanglante.
Où s'entassent désormais morts
et quelques prisonniers.
3000 Américains perdus sur la plus meurtrière
des 5 plages du débarquement.
Pourtant, en fin de journée,
le soleil revenu et après que les 1 ères lignes
aient enfin réussi à s'extraire de la nasse,
l'arrivée des troupes reprend sur Omaha.
Cette fois, on peut dire
que le débarquement a réussi.
Reste maintenant
à gagner la prochaine bataille,
celle de la Normandie et de la France.